hey what's up good folks this is john
with the dr john deloney show
today we are talking about adoption
heartbreak trauma
cancel culture immature in-laws
and vanilla ice it's 20 20 man we got
problems
where are you stay tuned
hey what's up good folks i'm john this
is dr john dalone's show
it's a color driven show we're talking
to real people about
real problems in real life
what kind of problems we're talking
about relationships relational iq
boyfriends and girlfriends trauma
mental health issues we're talking about
that person
who goes to the drive-through at
starbucks
and they order for the whole office
and it takes like 11 hours here's the
thing
get out of your car and make the oh so
treacherous journey
inside the people inside starbucks are
kind and lovely
they have this community they want to be
there they're so wonderful go inside and
don't
buy for your office in the drive-through
anyway if you want honesty you want a
second opinion
you want to tell me about your neighbor
or you just want advice worth
what you're paying for it i'm here to
walk with you
so give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-32
or you can email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
and here's the deal here's how it works
if you call the number you're going to
leave a message you're going to leave a
number where we can reach you and kelly
daniels going to call you back
and get you scheduled for the show and
if you shoot me an email leave your name
leave your number
tell me what's going on and again kelly
will reach out and we'll be in contact
to get you on the show
we've got a packed house today and so
we're gonna start with gracie
in oklahoma city gracie welcome to the
dr john dolone show how are you
i am so good dr john how are you i am
excellent
excellent how can i help well
i i think you're the guy to talk to i
have a
stressed relationship with my
father-in-law
and and and i don't want it to be that
way but um
tell me about it i just so we had a come
to jesus meeting about a year ago
and even after
even after apologies i still i still
just feel awkward i still feel
um it just maybe not all the gears are
greased
the gears of greece that's a very
oklahoma reference so i want to high
five you here from
nashville who needed to come to jesus
um so i think he and i both um
maybe we just we have mismatching
personalities
or maybe we have the same personality
and it clashes but
um so what happened what set off this
final this big meeting that had to
happen
so when i got married in 2015 and we
moved
to go work with my in-laws
and i mean i was homesick and
and so i wasn't i wasn't just
ready i feel like i didn't fit the mold
from the beginning
of what my father-in-law had in mind and
and so
we spent way too much time together over
the four years we were there and and the
reason the
the come to jesus meeting happened my
in-law my father-in-law was complaining
to my husband
and my husband said we we all need to
talk and so that's how this happened and
hold on i'm sorry your father-in-law
told your husband that he didn't like
you or didn't like your behavior or
whatever
and your husband told you honey you need
to go talk to my dad
no no no no he told his dad he stood up
to his dad for me
okay good for you that's a good oklahoma
guy right there there we go
i've got a great husband i do okay very
very cool all right i was about to
come out of my little chair here in
nashville okay that's good
and so y'all had that conversation how'd
it go
um it ended at results we put everything
out on the table
and um he said sorry i said sorry
and what did you have to be sorry about
um uh
i have a i have a blank stare sometimes
and it comes across as
rude as how he took it and although
i wasn't feeling negative toward him
about the things he he was
misinterpreting
my face so a grown
father a 50 or 60 year old man
needed an apology from his new
daughter-in-law because he doesn't like
the way her face looks
when she is having a neutral stare i
just want to ge
i'm laughing but but i'm just trying to
get to the bottom it is childish
okay it was four years of uh
i mean there were some things um that
were very petty
and instead of maybe talking about it
hey this bothered me from the beginning
it built up over time and kind of
exploded in this come to jesus meeting
okay and
so fast forward meet you right now
so he we said our stories uh
today what bothers me is whenever it's
his daughter's birthday or his other
daughter-in-law's birthday
he just loves them differently than he
does me and
it's okay if i'm not his favorite person
in the world but it just hurts me
and it it i have bitterness and
i see his outpour of love he does it on
facebook you're so wonderful
you're a great addition to this family
and i love you so much
and i don't get that and and i don't
want to be bitter
but that time of year of their birthdays
it just
it it really hurts me yeah
so i'm not going to break any new news
to you but i'll put it directly you've
got a very immature
father-in-law and it sounds like you've
got a wonderful husband
a good guy you did well but his dad is
immature
and at the end of the day you can't be
mature with immature you've got to just
walk away from it and
i know that puts you in an awkward
position because you're a
daughter-in-law as a part of a family
unit so when i say walk away that
doesn't mean that you
turn around and act immature and say
things like i don't go to birthday
parties i don't go to those kind of
things
but that means you just don't check
facebook that means maybe you don't even
follow the dude on facebook
like just a few years ago we all
interacted in the real world and we
weren't in the room with each other then
we just
didn't know what was going on and so you
may need to return to those places
because
now at this point you've got to do the
things that protect you and your
marriage
and what happens is if you reach out and
try to
check on the status of that relationship
how is he talking to his daughter how is
he talking to his other daughter-in-law
that makes puts bitterness in your heart
and at the end of the day
i'm gonna put that on you for choosing
to go pick that bitterness up and shove
it in your own backpack
right to pick it up and shove it in your
heart don't do that
because then you turn and look at this
awesome husband that you have
this awesome household that you have and
this
community of friends and church folks
whatever world you have created for
yourself
and you're continuing to create yourself
and you're just bringing that bitterness
and poison with you
so i'm just gonna tell you don't and at
some point
he may grow up probably not probably not
and it is super unfair it's
it's immature of me to lump west texas
guys of which i was one for 20 years um
oklahoma guys of which i've got a number
of close friends
there's just this bravado this hey yeah
and this is the way this is this way
it's always going to be
and you know what there's just nothing
you can do to change that
i've got close close friends who wrestle
with their dads on this same issue
um i've got close friends who have
wrestled with me on my attitude about
that issue so it is what it is what it
is what it is
at this point what you can control is
you you can continue to be mature you
continue to be respectful
and kind treat the man with dignity
don't be a jerk don't stoop to his
nonsensical
immature level right but at the same
time
man stop going to the well because
you're just going to get poisoned out of
it
you're just going to get poisoned out of
it and backing up
all father-in-laws out there all
mother-in-laws out there
you had a magic little picture you had
this little picture when you held your
little baby and they were sweet and
beautiful and kind and all the things
and you had the magic rocking chair that
you rocked them in
you probably didn't rock them but you
think you did and you have all these
these
these
images and then they bring home some
knucklehead or they bring home some girl
with brown hair instead of blonde hair
or they bring home some guy who's got
long hair instead of
wranglers on whatever the thing is
that is your problem to solve
you in-laws
need to love your kids and love the
person that you raised them to do
raise them to be love them
because that's your problem and here's
the thing about problems
2020 is full of problems parents are
full of
everyone's got problems and i was
thinking about my problems the other day
and
kelly daniels sent me this phenomenal
text
i was in the middle of reading medical
journals articles
trying to get smarter for this podcast
show
helping me get smarter is a long
treacherous road right it's
a long journey through my thick skull
and i couldn't get past this one problem
i was trying to wrap my head around
like america's got problems like in-laws
have problems and kelly daniel
the oracle that she is sends me a text
and she reminded me of wisdom i learned
in sixth grade
and it was this i was told
that if i had a problem yo he'd solve it
i just needed to check out the hook
while the dj revolved it vanilla iceman
where
are you dude you said you would solve
all of our problems
2020 sucks the world's falling apart we
have
father-in-laws who treat their
daughter-in-laws like garbage because of
the way they look at their because their
face their facial expression listen
ice brother you told me that sometimes
there are girlies on standby waiting
just to say hi but no you've got to
just hit the gas and drive by to go
solve the problems ice we're waiting for
you man we are waiting for you
okay let's go to robert in orlando i'm
gonna stop right there robert
orlando brother what is up hey john uh
thanks for having me on
thank you thank you good man for calling
how can i help
so uh my wife and i are
looking at adopting my
uh nephews but there's a
bigger complication in um
the first word that popped in my head
when you said we're thinking of adopting
nephews i just thought that's
complicated
so unwind it for us man all right so
my it's technically my cousins but they
are
my great aunt who is in her 70s
adopted two young boys uh are
seven and five and there was some
very serious family issues uh with the
kids before she adopted them who's their
parents
who's their parents uh they are both
out of the picture uh one mother died
the father isn't there
oh so so this your 70 year old great
aunt
wasn't picking up like two kids that
were in the family she just went out and
adopted two kids on her own
oh no no they were in they were in her
family but there was drug issues
there were okay all right i'm just
making sure that she didn't just get
like emotional one day and watch the
right video
and just decide you know oh no no no get
myself two toddlers
or two young kids okay okay right no no
so she did a really noble thing
which is she stepped in in a gap of
someone in the family
who wasn't living up to their their
parents responsibility she picked up a
five-year-old and uh and how old you say
five and a seven-year-old five and a
seven seven yeah well
she's had them since they were babies
right in her house since they were
babies and then
because of other issues in the family
she just adopted them
okay um so she's a gangster right she's
awesome oh she is amazing
right what a stunt what a stud woman
okay she's amazing
uh but you know her being in that age
she her health is starting to decline
her
uh you know there are some issues
uh so i am my wife and i
have been discussing with her for the
last
i don't know four or five years that
when and if something happens
we would gladly begin the process of
taking in the boys
and start introducing them into our
family because we are probably the best
option
okay uh however she has a
live-in helper now who
was also part of this situation
in that she was the
girlfriend of her son of my aunt's son
right and so now her son is no longer in
the picture so do this for me robert
we are quickly turning into the jerry
springer podcast so let's like
zero it in for me you guys are going to
get these or one i picked up these two
right beautiful pick up these two kids
okay but
we're worried that the current
long time keeper is
is pop introducing some new
creation or whispering in her ear that
she would be the better option but we're
worried because she doesn't have
any jobs she doesn't have any long-term
goals it doesn't even look like she has
a
driver's license at the moment and so
we're we're a little worried about that
side of it so have you
have you are you and your wife if if
your if your great aunt came and said
today
we're ready i'm ready to pull the
trigger would you all be ready to take
them today
100 we've even got a bedroom ready have
you all done the home study and you're
all ready to rock and roll
i guess we haven't we haven't completed
the home study but we've
started the process okay all right so
the second option is
i mean the second thing is when's the
last time you sat down
seriously and said we're ready uh
well we tried to on sunday okay tell me
about that conversation
okay so so that conversation was uh
we sat down with her we said hey
we want to start looking at our
long-term
options here because we're also in a in
you know financial position to possibly
start buying a house and all of that
and we want to know what the best
options are going to be for us and then
that's when she told us hey the the
this person is actually going to be the
one that's probably going to take in the
boys
okay so
here's the hard news there if that's
what the legal guardian wants to do with
those boys that's what's going to happen
right that's heartbreaking and hard and
you guys can go to court and try to sue
over it and try to get an attorney that
will
disparage and blow up the care givers
you know the home caregivers life and
all that
um or you and your wife can
begin the painful harsh process of
grieving the loss of what you thought
the future picture of your life was
going to look like and start reimagining
it or if this person is a chump
right this caregiver is like you said
it's got no jobs got no
driver's license has no ambition just
wants power just wants to take these two
kids as though they're
pets um then it's just going to delay
your
they're moving to your house anyway at
some point right
but it doesn't sound like you guys have
a lot of leverage other than
to deal with you the heartbreak that's
going to be inside your house
do you feel pretty committed that your
great aunt has just has made this
decision and it's over
um i don't know
the the like i said the
her well her health is declined and i
think she's just
trying to move forward as quickly as
possible in the
event of an emergency okay so so tell me
this
do you want those kids to live with you
absolutely do you want to be the parent
of those kids
absolutely okay so this morning
i've got i've got a number of friends
and it's a heartbreaking season
covet has just done a number on
relationships across the country i've
got a number of friends whose marriages
are they found their marriages in wacky
rocky places
and i was talking to one particular
friend this morning and
she was walking me through a series of
situations that she's
stuck in right now and i told her
you must go fight for your kids
and i want to encourage you the best you
can and when i say fight don't go be
ridiculous and don't go be immature
fighting for you in this situation is
setting up a dinner this week with your
great aunt
either go to her house if if she's not
mobile or
invite her off site get her out of the
house out of the picture
and tell her hey i'm uncomfortable with
the conversation we had on sunday
my wife and i are ready to buy a house
we have started the home study process
we've been in those boys lives
and we want to in no uncertain terms we
want to adopt
those kids we want them to be ours we
want them to move to our home you've
done an extraordinary heroic job
getting them from being a toddler to now
and we are ready to take over
and we'd love to have you come over all
the time and still be super involved in
their life as long as your health can
handle that
but i think at this point you got to be
aggressive and go out and say
this is what i want and then put her on
the spot and say no i've chosen somebody
else
okay and then you does that make sense
and then you and your wife get some
clarity
and then you all know and again i'm not
going to discourage you from going to
get a lawyer if you think this other
person's bad and the kids are going to
be in bad shape or bad health
go do what you need to do if you think
that's more
you looking in the mirror and saying i
would be better than this person
then that's your own baggage that you
got to deal with right right
but at the end of the day i want you to
go fight for your kids if that's who
you if you i mean if you think they're
your kids and
you are setting up a home for those kids
then go fight for them go
tell your great aunt nope i don't like
how that conversation went their hours
i want them to be hours we're ready to
adopt ready to pull the trigger right
now
okay how does that sound yes
i i yeah that that does give me
at least at least something that will
give me some more clarity
so that's that's what i need is is to
know yes or no and then like you said
if i need to grieve that that's not what
our our life is gonna take us then i
need to agree that
okay and here's the deal grieving is
gonna look like this
grieving is gonna look like you and your
wife and probably some close friends
maybe some people from your church maybe
some people from your softball league
and that's you coming over to your house
inviting them over and you all have a
ceremony
a small miniature get-together that says
a collective funeral a collective
grieving moment for
what wasn't having a ceremony
is so important to mark something a
moment
of our life was going one way and it is
now suddenly going another way
and having those markers there puts a
time stamp in it puts a flag in the
ground
and it becomes an important touchstone
down the road when you can remember this
is the moment when we said
regardless what happened life's going
left life's going right and we thought
it was going straight
and it just gives you this tether to
then you can begin the
painful awful struggle of planning on
what's gonna
what tomorrow's gonna bring right do you
go back to the adoption agency
do you have biological kids whatever
whatever your story is going to unfold
down the road right
but it gives you a touchdown moment so
make sure when you agree this you grieve
it with a
a ceremony and then you're probably
going to get somebody to walk alongside
you and your wife as you all transition
from one thing to another but i honestly
don't want to go there yet robert i want
you to go have that conversation with
your great aunt i want you to look in
the eye and say
those are my kids we want them to be
ours we are ready to pull the trigger
right now and we want you to be a part
of their life even though they're going
to start transitioning and moving in
with us
and put her on the spot and see what she
says she may just surprise you okay
so thanks for the call robert i want to
transition over to an email
man this one's a good one this is an
email from greg it's one sentence
usually emails are
stories they're long and they are
drawn out this is quick and to the point
greg
asks can you tell me dr d
how you feel about the cancel culture
how do i feel about the cancer culture
man here we go greg
here's what i think about the cancel
culture i think number one
i think this idea that we go dredging
through
minutes years decades of people's lives
trying to find the worst things they
have done the stupid things they have
said the
the times they fell down when getting on
a bike and we dragged that stuff
up to the front we dragged it up to the
now
and we hold them accountable for things
they did when they were children
when they were younger when they were
immature
when society said here's a different
story here's a different narrative
i think that's dangerous i think that's
unfounded and i think that's
ridiculous quite honestly i
love the idea of education i've been a
teacher for 20 something years i love
the idea of
growing that's that's the whole reason i
do what i do i love mental health
i love being a part of counseling and
coaching sessions i love these calls
here
because here's why i love the idea of
somebody going down a road
and somebody's showing them hey that
hurts that's painful
that is not helpful and then giving
people the opportunity and the tools to
go
oh man i'm so sorry let me help let me
move let me shift
because the one thing that is
sure to shove people's hearts and their
actual motives
and their ability to change who they are
way underground
is to let them know the moment you pop
your head above
the ground i'm going to cut it off the
moment i find you said something way
long ago i'm coming for you i want
people in my life to have scars i want
them to have said you know what i used
to think this joke was funny
for years i thought it was funny and
then somebody looked me in the eye and
said
this hurts this is painful this sucks
and if you say this again
dot dot dot and then give people the
opportunity to say i am sorry never
again
never again but this idea of one
striking you're out and it's one strike
retroactively
i just think it's painful it's dangerous
it's a really scary movement for our
culture in general
it's not a grace-filled way of moving
forward
that said if you are an idiot
if you've got things in your past that
you need to repent of that you need to
come out and say dude
i used to think these jokes were funny i
used to treat people like this
i used to fill in the blank
you've got to decide to be different
right
and my rule of thumb is man if i say
something offensive if i say something
that i didn't mean to or i see something
that hurts somebody and they come let me
know hey listen
listen when the way you say this that's
man that hurts a whole swath of people
that's not cool or your idea on how to
deal with whatever issue that's actually
not factually correct it's the way to do
it
is like this then i get to choose to
grow or then i get to choose to go to
war
and my hope is that people will shift
their default setting and
choose growth instead but man if it is
cancel
if it is i can't wait to find something
about you so i can end you
i just i think that's a dangerous
trajectory for all of us
and it's not fundamentally helpful it
just shoves
all the nonsense nonsense underground
it just makes it all um
i don't know it makes everybody go
silent makes everybody go dark and that
is not how you heal things you heal
things in the light
you heal things with openness you heal
things with vulnerability you hear heal
things with forgiveness and pardon
and so greg that's what i think about
cancer culture i'm not a fan of it i
think it's got dangerous trajectory
and it's a scary place to go and it's
really forcing a lot of our
smartest most extraordinary minds and
thinkers to just keep their mouths shut
to just not say anything because it's
not worth the risk man it's not worth
the risk
and that's not helpful for anybody we
need more poets we need more songwriters
we need more
thinkers we need more scientists more
people questioning and asking hard
questions and being able to say things
and yes we were all stupid when we were
kids that's why we were
i mean that's that's why the society as
as large has said you know what let's
don't let uh
16 year olds buy cigarettes because they
don't make good decisions
right that's why we don't let 18 year
olds buy guns
right or buy beer because they're 18
they don't make great decisions
we'll give them 150 000 to go to college
we do that that's stupid but
we we have as a society have said hey
you know what brains aren't totally
formed yet
we do let 35 year olds and 40 year olds
go to grad school why because they're
capable of learning new things and
changing the way they see the world
and so let's give people the opportunity
to grow and learn and change their heart
and mind
so greg man you can tell i probably do a
whole show on canceled culture someday
but
um that's my thoughts on that all right
let's go back to the phones let's go to
sarah
in toronto canada sarah
good morning from the united states how
are we doing
good morning hi dr john thanks so much
for taking my call
thank you for calling how can i help you
this morning
okay so i went through a really
traumatic c-section
um about 15 months ago man i'm so sorry
yeah um so about like i said 13 months
ago i went to labor
everything seemed fine at first um this
is my second
child um towards the 10-hour mark they
noticed his heart rate
dropping fast and they weren't sure what
was wrong with him and they
just made the quick decision to rush me
into the or so i didn't really have time
to process
this whole thing um when they started
um i felt everything about my c-section
i felt
them cutting i felt hard sorry it's hard
for me to talk about but um
i felt some cutting i felt them moving
my organs i felt everything um
i remember pleading with the
anesthesiologist
um pleading with my husband he was in
the room he
was having a hard time hearing me
because i was just so weak i remember
going in and out of consciousness
blacking out a lot um i felt like i was
having panic attacks
um while they were having surgery uh
while i was having the surgery
um the whole thing lasted about eight
minutes and
towards the end they finally drug me up
with something i just knocked
out for hours so now
you know a little over a year um i just
get
really intense flashbacks thankfully
they're not daily
i can look at my son i can see my scar
and i'm not
traumatized daily but i get the random
flashbacks
and i just don't know how to move past
and brings up a lot of anxiety
for future surgeries um a lot of fear
attached to it as well um that was my
first ever surgery
and i just don't know how
i would handle the thought of having
another one or having more kids
in case i need another c-section um so i
just
would like if you have any advice to um
to give
yeah there's a lot here first and
foremost that sucks nobody should ever
have to go through that
and i want you to know sarah that's not
the way it's supposed to be
and i hate that you went through that
okay
i want you to hear that the second thing
is is
one of my little throwaway lines my
little um
i don't know their little pinteresty
quotes that don't mean a whole lot
actually mean something in this moment
and anxiety is fear of the future
right it's this this inability to
control what's what's happening
um especially what come what may we
don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow the next day or the next day
in your case this transcends anxiety
this is true fear
because you have been in a situation
where you lost control and the people
that
we all as a community as a culture
trust to take care of us in those
moments medical professionals they
failed you
okay and i don't think they failed you
on purpose i don't think anybody ceases
i mean enters those moments to do that
but
the goal there is is to protect you and
to protect that baby
and thankfully they were there to help
that baby and to take care of that baby
but man you had surgery performed on you
without anesthesia and you remember it
and so these flashbacks are ways that
your body reminds you to never let that
happen again
and that's the work that you need to do
have you gone to see somebody
um i know a lot of my family members
have told me to
speak with my doctors at the therapist
um i think my fair
with that is i don't want to be put in
a dark place i don't know i know it's
going to be a journey i know
it's not going to be a one quick fix one
session i can go to
so i know i need to go through it for a
while and i just
my mind i'm not sure if i can handle
that i know
that's what you need to do but it's just
hard to
to think of speaking about it often and
going
to that dark place often but yeah i know
i need to speak with someone
so here's the thing with an acute trauma
like this
an acute means like a laser beam or a
razor think about it very sharp and
direct okay
with an acute trauma the exit
is often not as lengthy and painful as
you think it might be
you are right you're gonna have to go
there um
if you find a great therapist who can do
things like emdr
or i've seen some neat stuff with brain
spotting
even tfcbt which is trauma focused
cognitive behavioral therapy it's
usually for children but in moments like
this can be really powerful
you're not talking a whole bunch of
sessions you're talking about 10 or 11
and those sessions are broken up in how
to talk
to yourself how to learn to
self-regulate when those thoughts pop in
your head
and then you go through that trauma
again and then you go out the back end
of it
and there's a remarkable cathartic
moment the the
research efficacy on those programs is
really extensive it's really
extraordinary
emdr moments to help you your brain
reset itself i want you to do a fun
exercise for me okay
okay um so i want you to close your eyes
and i'm going to take this directly from
david kessler who's the
the grief and trauma expert on planet
earth
i want you to close your eyes and i want
you to picture a purple elephant
okay okay
i want you to picture a purple a purple
elephant in your driveway
just standing there with a hat on his
head okay do you have that picture in
your head
yeah okay i want you to open your eyes
now what you have just done is prove to
america and the entire world
that you can control your thoughts
okay and so what a
counselor will help you do in these
moments is control those intrusive
painful thoughts that firebomb into your
head out of nowhere
and what you will learn is that it's
like a muscle and that over time you
will be able to
slowly and uh you'll slowly grow that
muscle to where you are stronger and
stronger when that thought pops in there
you see your baby and by this time he's
gonna be riding a tricycle around and
you flash to that moment
you'll be able to go nope not doing it
and literally you can
you can move it out but that's like me
telling you right now hey you can just
go to a crossfit gym and just crank out
75
pull-ups right you've gotta practice
that and you need a coach
and you need someone to walk alongside
you and that's what a therapist is gonna
do
if you walk into a counselor and they
tell you all right i want you to tell me
everything that happened on session one
just say thank you but i'm gonna leave
because you're not a good trauma
counselor you don't know what you're
doing and people can re-injure you
and like you said make things pretty
dark if they don't know what they're
doing
but i want you to find i guarantee you
in toronto there are some extraordinary
trauma counselors
that you can talk about your situation
they will help you walk
out of that situation with a set of
skills
to begin to take control of your
thoughts to begin to
reframe some of those moments and really
just stop the intrusion
because surgery can be an extraordinary
thing it can be a really remarkable gift
and occasionally occasionally it's a
painful painful trauma
so again sarah i am so sorry that
happened to you that sucks
and here's the other thing don't lose
the trauma here too
there's this innate trauma that my body
didn't work like it was supposed to
and i've known a number of women who
carry around a
deep deep trauma that's beyond the
physical trauma which is why did my body
do what it was supposed to do
and make sure you discuss that with your
counselor as well
this idea that my body is supposed to be
a machine it's supposed to
a plus b is supposed to equal c our
bodies don't work like that
they're still beautiful they're still
extraordinary and sometimes things
happen
and that's when the medical community is
supposed to come in and help us and
unfortunately didn't go well for you
this time
please reach out to somebody again emdr
tfcbt if you can find somebody that will
do a modified version that for you as an
adult
find a trauma counselor in your area
bite down on your mouthpiece head into
the ring there do the hard work to go
get well
it will be worth it on the back end for
you for your husband
for those beautiful beautiful kids of
yours and for whatever adventure you are
going to co-create
moving down the road thank you so so
much for your call sarah you're a gift
and a blessing thank you for calling
all right and so as we wrap up today's
show i want to leave us with
easily i'm just gonna put it out there
it's the greatest song of all time it
was written back in 1981
by the the reverend billy joe shaver
i just imagined him walking into his
backyard with a pen and a paper
walking past an old rusty tin can where
he could see his reflection and he
thought
i'm just an old chunk of coal
and his heart channeled down his arm and
threw his pen and here's what he wrote
billy joe laments hey i'm just an old
chunk of coal
but i'm gonna be a diamond someday i'm
gonna grow and glow
till i'm so blue pure perfect
i'm gonna put a smile on everybody's
face i'm just an old chunk of coal now
lord but i'm going to be a diamond
someday
this has been the dr john dolone's show